[Applause]
you're talking about barbed wire again
this is an issue for all right this is
like that Russell Crowe movie I don't
member worth all that one then I saw one
time he never heard of again
oh it's Master and Commander oh yeah
you're right it didn't have an awesome
soundtrack no what no shoot him okay try
to hit that max hello Calum justjust
distract them tell them a story and
focus their predators elsewhere whoops
no there's just one time oh no they're
distracting us did it alarm you but
we're in trouble they're far better
oh good mate he's here no go away your
distraction tactic never works we
weren't you know likes gotta get out of
here man I'm stuck in this well I'm
bummed my own shed god damn it I can't I
can't man
okay I'm stuck in the
[Laughter]
okay okay I don't think I'm playing this
game correctly our ship keeps blowing up
from our shoot oh shoot yeah I'm not
sure what's going on don't cannon that's
not good don't worry Emma shoot down
there their mass police take their boat
it's like that one movie uh-huh
who's on my team this time it's you and
me minx EMU okay we're gonna we're gonna
use a different tactic this time around
just yeah no you're gonna shoot them
here they're crazy
janym aiming higher we don't have any
logical rules you were criticizing my
pie logic gold and wenches we don't like
anything else
yeah so we don't care about sniping we
care about you know rum wenches and gold
but we have plenty of this do you listen
we won't fight you if you give us all
your wenches 70% of my body isn't wrong
I tried you said there was no pirate
logic winning with that sure the minks
we got the right way we wanted no
shootin bears are the right into our
trap
[Laughter]
Oh Oh doh
okay that's real Club keep shooting
minks ten man the cannons I captain oh
yeah a nice shine we need that to sail I
should really we're gonna we're gonna
crash the land or whatever
I shall we go oh I don't want to be a
part of anymore
oh it me yep
easy stop trying to shoot me please I'm
just the captain your salty dog's what
the hell salty dog's is not better than
lion crabs this moaning point that
captain oh I want to kill the captain so
bad you keep shooting at me I don't like
it
Oh Yuri I'm so scared we're so dead
peace I'm Manning my station I'm no
matter what I'm not giving you I am
going to kill ya
please don't I have to it's part of my
code
[Applause]
way to do that was inevitable I can't
keep up thinking about mink like you
need this to sail our ship yes nice they
can move down we could still go there
using wizard powers I knew it you
thought yet alright guys hope you
enjoyed another episode of pirate Juarez
ship men ship horse maybe like if you
don't watching its the sky a common
birthday see you brothers in the next
one say awesome I'm not gonna punch you
it's a brofist I look so scared
alright no seed on that I guess I'll
just
[Applause]
[Music]